mais là messieurs bonsoir la vérité et
toute la vérité jaillira tel ce soir de
la reconstitution du meurtre de la
petite christelle rien n'est moins sûr
et pourtant cette reconstitution pour
organiser trois mois après le drame
constitue une étape essentielle sinon
décisive dans l'instruction que mène le
juge lehmann ce soir dès la nuit tombée
le principal inculpé et assassin présumé
christian jack eto'o sera extrait de sa
cellule pour être conduits dans le
quartier de metz belle croix là il devra
revivre la soirée du 25 février dernier
au cours de laquelle la petite
christelle a été assassiné
christian-jacques eto'o le meurtrier
présumé de la pitite christelle fera
t-il ce soir les gestes qui ont conduit
au meurtre
le 25 février dernier de christelle
bareback fabrice relevé le principal
témoin à charge à mimer la scène en lieu
et place de jack et au le 20 avril lors
d'un transport de justice
j'ai assisté aux moeurs de la gamine
avait il dit alors depuis il n'est pas
revenu sur ses accusations lors de sa
confrontation avec jack est haut dans le
bureau du juge nicole lehmann jeudi
dernier il a confirmé ses dires
j'ai vu tchèque et au ce dernier nie
continuera-t-il ce soir a nié en
refusant de faire les gestes qu'on lui
prête
rien n'est moins sûr ses avocats
craignent en effet qu'il ne se laisse
aller animer ces gestes d'un crime qu'il
n'aurait pas commis
parce qu'il ne comprend pas ce qu'on lui
veut pourquoi nous ne la saisissons pas
ce soir parce que notre présence
donnerait à penser que ce qui va être
fait quelque chose qui a été mûrie
quelque chose qui est résonnait quelque
chose qui auraient été conservés comme
il est normal entre un client et des
avocats
nous ne pouvons pas discuter avec ce
genre de clients des expertises
psychiatriques n'a pas lieu nous ne
comprenons pas notre client cela dit
cette reconstitution est essentiel pour
l'instruction qui jusqu'àlors a bien eu
du mal à cerner la réalité des faits
tels qu'ils ont pu se dérouler ce samedi
25 février